look at that this is actually a
depiction of a swan but what do you see
what do you feel I feel you don't live
here Ronnie she could stay here but I
can't get a dog she's my sister there's
a difference yeah there's a difference
you can have sex in front of a
dog today's a big day for Anna they're
doing one of those big
auctions if I want to work at a top Art
Gallery I got to get a good
recommendation and there is no better
recommendation than Claire
Dupont good morning everyone Irwin's
clients are about to walk through that
door and I will not allow them to see
anything less than Perfection you what's
that massive oil spill on the back of
your shirt it's not like we work for a
sociopathic perfectionist or anything oh
God hello it's Claire your boss I need
an extra assistant I just got invited to
go to London with Claire
Dupont you're not on this flight I put
you on one that leaves in 4 hours an
economy you just been upgraded first
class I'm William what brings you to
London our London branch has called in
the director of the New York office wow
you seem a bit young to be the director
yeah the youngest director in company
history if you're not too busy being a
Swanky art director I would love to take
you out I lied to him about so many
things you are here for work not for
play I got you the reservation tickets
for this
evening can invite me inside excuse me
what happened to your manners down
tabi mom she's a director of an auction
house in New
York I would like you in charge of my
auction I'm going to do it I'm jealous
of your P Montana
lifestyle Santos a word
please you're a New Yorker and being a
New Yorker means that you fight every
single
day Rocky bbo said that isn't he from
Philly he moved there from
[Music]
Brooklyn